so what you do is you create your own
curriculum that is above and beyond what
uh
is handed to you and i think you know i
think about what was handed to me
education wise and how i kind of blew it
and i talked about that in the book
there's a whole chapter on creating your
own curriculum
it was based on a tweet this guy did
frank fleming said that if you actually
took all the education
time 16 like 16 years of education
and kind of curated what you wanted to
do you would be batman
16 years of like martial arts philosophy
languages or you would be or economics
you would be batman
but instead you have 16 years of
education
and you're applying for jobs you know in
pharmaceutical sales and you're hoping
you will get that job
[Music]
all right gutfeld look you wrote a book
you wrote a book here this is what your
27th book how many books now yes
this is book number nine or
what i like to say yeah i like to say
it's eight more than yours
dave eight more books than yours i can't
even see your first book it's so early
it's like call me when you're on your
fifth book
then i can get the patches on my elbows
and the whole thing and be an esteemed
writer
like you you'll be like judd hirsch in
ordinary people
you are going into your sort of jd
salinger phase though of life i can tell
because you've got your house
in the undisclosed location in the woods
you occasionally tweet pictures you're
on a lake
surrounded by trees and things you're
sort of going into that you're thought
of as a as a cable news guy but you're
what really drives you is the desire to
be off the grid
hidden in the woods true or false i i
believe
that i was self-distancing before it was
cool
i am i don't know what it was it was
because i was younger i was more social
but i have no desire like you know me
when you're in new york it is impossible
to even get me out of my apartment
you know literally you end up yes
and every i made you come to my
apartment
when it was destroyed because i would
rather sit in my apartment that had just
been flooded
than actually like oh david's going meet
me at this restaurant i go you know i
don't really feel like
but i'm like greg name the restaurant
it's on me
whatever you want you know grass-fed
this you're like could you just come to
my place i have
i have one beer yes
[Laughter]
i'm not that bad i always have booze but
we did go to del frisco's
remember we did go to dallas coast
across the world that was
that that was nice nice guy
yeah so it was your brother right you
told me that was your brother
yeah okay i claimed it was my brother he
he says he's my brother
i'm not sure um no but let let's talk
about the
the quarantine stuff a little bit
because because in your book you
actually you
i guess you added the preface after you
wrote the whole thing because then you
wanted to address the quarantine stuff
and they they let you jam it in there
yeah it was interesting because we had
to have a discussion whether something
in the news
ends up branding your book or should
your book be above it all
so i'm i'm the book's going to bed and
all this
stuff is happening and the book itself
is about a collective response
to crap in your life so that we all
share the risk and be better people
and this thing is happening and i'm
going i have this has to go in the book
because all of the things in the book
the collective response prison to two
ideas
unbending minds uh blaming and
forgiveness
all fit you could all point all of these
tips in that direction
and um but there was like there were
people going yeah but you don't want to
be a pandemic book and i go well you
know what
if this book had come out in 2016 we
would be talking about the trump
election
if it had been coming out in 12 2012 it
would be obama you know it or or
if it came out in 2001 it would be 911.
so you you you can't
ignore reality so i put it in there and
it it
in um it's weird a lot all the chapters
in this book
are are dealing with crap that happened
later
like even the riots in them all this
likes i talk about
social media i talk about uh uh
marginalization demonization all this
stuff and it's like everything is
happening
and it makes i i it's it kind of scares
me because i'm trying to be positive
and the book is trying to be positive
but we're in a time where we're not sure
if we can be positive anymore you know
no
well nobody's nobody's sure of anything
but i will go on the record gutfeldt is
saying that if anyone watching this
enjoy
don't burn this book they will dig the
plus because actually a lot of a lot of
the themes
i mean this is why we do so much stuff
together lately a lot of the themes that
both of us care about
related to free speech what's happening
at the college is trying to keep
some semblance of western society
organized
maintaining a sense of humor through it
all that that really
is what the thrust of this is about but
on the on the self-help side
do you sense that people over the last
four months that there's going to be
like when when this thing is done
if it's if it's ever done that that
there will be a real split where it'll
be like
some people really will have gotten
their lives in order
lost weight learned how to cook started
new hobbies etc etc and then there will
be this other set of people that will
just like completely lost control of
their lives
and i know both sides of that of that
equation
it's kind of like the it's it's like the
education argument that like you could
just go to high school
check in and check out and you come out
worse or you can be that kid that goes
oh i want to do this i want to go i'm
going to be like the dana perino i'm
going to join the speech and debate club
because that's going to make me better
and i'm going to and then i'm going to
go uh play
bad with field hockey i'm trying to
think of sports but i mean it's like
it's like lacrosse create
lacrosse thank you so what you do is you
create your own curriculum
that is above and beyond what uh is
handed to you
and i think you know i think about what
was handed to me education wise and how
i kind of blew it and i talked about
that in the book there's a whole chapter
on creating your own curriculum
it was based on a tweet this guy did
frank fleming said that if you actually
took
all the education time 16 like 16 years
of education
and kind of curated what you wanted to
do you would be batman
16 years of like martial arts philosophy
languages or you would be or economics
you would be batman
but instead you have 16 years of
education
and you're applying for jobs you know in
pharmaceutical sales and you're hoping
you will get that job
because you did not think about it like
what an incredible
opportunity so that's how i started
thinking about the pandemic it's like
okay the cards that are being dealt are
limiting everything
like i can't go to the gym which i've
been going for 40 years i guess
to the gym like every week for 40 years
and that's over
and i know how much i eat i eat a
buttload of food
so this is not going to end well for me
also i tend to you know i like
drinking and i'm going to be home a lot
and there's al so all of these variables
are pointing in a terrible direction for
me
and i thought well what if i decided to
create
like a quote scott adams a system
uh rather than goals and so like cut out
the get cut out the starches and the and
the carbohydrates and then
and then it's like get a bike and get up
every morning and start early
and then and also what i get up every
morning and walk
before i exercise and i just to get
sunlight all this stuff
and all of a sudden it just like i it
made me
it's like i i took i went to school to
become a better person
which was weird because that's what the
book's about the book was about becoming
better
at being you yeah kind of interesting
well it's kind of interesting because
how can you become a better dave rubin
well i mean i've i've done it you know
what i mean
what you're going through right now is
where i was a year ago you'll get to the
perfect place greg come on
and i'm going to help i'm going to help
you get there um
thank you but it it is kind of
interesting because you wrote the book
obviously before the pandemic then you
add this part about the pandemic but
yeah what you were writing about
and sort of getting your life together
really kind of is what you're trying to
show
for other people but that kind of
reminds me you wrote a piece on
foxnews.com about a year ago
about how people can educate themselves
outside of the system you can learn from
jordan peterson you can go on youtube
and learn from biologists and chemists
and all of those things
does that strike you the fact that young
people
still even now as we watch colleges
collapse
does it seem just completely crazy to
you that they're still putting all that
money in on that
experiment yeah there needs to be okay
okay so there's that old experiment that
we see is failing
and it looks like the pandemic is going
to push it
online and elsewhere and then here is
the perfect thing which is to have
you know shows like yours or youtube
anything on youtube like you
getting a biology class from brett
weinstein or getting a philosophy class
for jordan peterson
but the the uh instructors have to be
really good
it can't just be like youtube where you
like i gets
i get stuck in a youtube black hole
looking for um guitar instruction
and so it's like how to play rockabilly
guitar so i hit that
it's 30 minutes and the guy's talking
for eight minutes
and he's like and he's just talking he's
holding his guitar and it's like i can't
do this
i need like somebody who's an instructor
and i think that's the only missing
point because you have the
you have the vehicle you have youtube
you've got the internet
and you have the desire the people to
want to do this you have the pandemic
that is forcing people in this direction
all that's missing is the pro the
stylistic
charismatic instructor and i go back to
peloton
every time what peloton did to gyms
is what instructors are going to do to
college so
i no longer need to go to a gym again
because the peloton instructor
is so amazing so smart and so
authentic and and i love this girl
hannah frankson she's british
i get up every morning and she gets me
on that bike and she she
it's what she's done is she's taken the
product and she's
delivered it to you in the best way
possible that's the way
there has to be colleges that start up
with that model that says okay
you need great professors and they got
to be funny they got to be smart they
got to be
not bad looking everybody in peloton is
great looking
and they're funny and and uh and so i
think that's the peloton model for
education
is going to be the solution for all of
this and i'm not the
i think that scott adams talked said
this to me before in an interview that
it's like this is the step
that's necessary is to get likable
talented
persuasive people to be the instructor
and so now you're going to get those
people leaving these colleges
but there has to be something to come to
and it's got to be like jordan peterson
teaches
introduction to apologetics or whatever
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell